foreign
I entered into an affair with a married
man and it's been off and on how do I
handle the loneliness of ending it I
have moments where I'm very strong and
I'm like I can handle this you know deep
down this whole thing ends in Ash
[Music]
what are you doing this is John with the
Dr John deloney show
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting and love and figuring out what
comes next
podcast YouTube show that's ever existed
ever in the history of time except for
the original OG Frazier crane that guy
was onto something but
since they took Frazier crane off the
air I'm here to fill the gaps
um I just got back from Texas
and it's
I just needed to say this out loud
I don't know what y'all have done to
that state
but it's always been hot
now it's like visiting a convection oven
that got left on like a week ago
and all the internal components have
just melted
if you're not in Texas you should go
outside and just lay down in your front
yard and make a snow angel and look up
to the sky and just say thank you to
whatever whatever you believe in if you
are in Texas May the force be with you
and I'm going home the last weekend of
September for a football game
it needs to stop it's going to be 1 000
degrees I was trying to explain to
somebody it wasn't from Texas that in
Texas like in Sunday school they teach
you that hell is cold because when
they're like it's so hot everyone's like
okay like it's not a reason we're like
yeah it's not a reason to not do bad
things yeah yeah that's Wednesday and so
all I can say is I'm happy to be back in
Nashville Tennessee and if you want to
be on this show I just I don't know it's
so hot it's still in my bones
golly and I'm in the air conditioning
it's uh if you want to be on the show
1-844-693-3291
-844-693-3291 go to John delaney.com ask
um building a non-interest life still on
pre-sale please go pick it up go to John
deloney.com it's 20 bucks and I'll send
you a bunch of other stuff to bribe you
into doing it early thank you so so much
for the thousands and thousands of
people who've already pre-ordered it man
it's just amazing you're just I'm just
so grateful all right let's run out to
oh look at that we're going back to
Texas to my hometown in h-tone and let's
talk to Katie Katie what's up
hey Dr John how are you
I'm still recovering from being in Texas
this last few days
what have you all done I I'm still
wondering not myself yeah it's a steam
room that you can't escape from that's a
great way to say that and then when you
get your car and the air conditioner's
on you're just all wet
yeah
I mean you can walk to your mailbox and
be drenched in sweat it's ridiculous
ease
plus who still gets mail all right so
what's up how can I help
that would have been way funnier if it
was m-a-l-e Box by the way that'd been
hilarious I don't even know what that
that's a great place for like a like a
like like male dancers it should be
called the mailbox and it's just m-a-l-e
I think would that be funny Kelly no I
would imagine somebody's already come up
with that somewhere or the mail room am
I Ellie I don't know I think they'll be
hilarious all right Katie what's up
um okay I'm gonna try my very best to
make it a very poignant question
um but basically
I entered into
an affair with a married man a couple
years ago and it's been off and on
and A lot's happened but what I my
question is
is how do I handle
the loneliness
of ending it
um that I'm going to feel
and
how do I go about my day-to-day with my
job being around family and friends and
having this heavy weight
that I'm caring and ending a
relationship with someone that I've been
very deeply attached to for
many many years
So when you say a lot happened thank you
number one thing for your question you
asked that perfect
um when you say a lot happened there's a
lot in that sentence what do you mean
unpack that for me
so started out as we were co-workers
um this goes back 10 years
um and
and we you know he was married and so
and I wasn't attracted to him at all and
I had never been in a relationship
before I started dating very late in
life I've always kept my guard up
against guys
um and so I've always had this wall up
but he came along and
slowly you know started kind of breaking
those walls down
um it would start with just banter about
work related things non-work related
things in the office and and we kind of
became friends and
so it became an emotional affair long
before it became a physical one
um and so about six years in
um
I could sense that he was attracted to
me
um but he knew that I I was you know
very inexperienced and you know I had
never really dated anybody but there was
always this flirtation going on and um
and then one day he asked me Point Blank
if I had feelings for him because he had
feelings for me
so we had a very long discussion and I
said yes I do but I there's nothing that
we can do about it because you're
married
and um
so a couple months go by and I'm it's
like this big elephant in the room now
we can't be the same around each other
and
and I start to feel this very strong
desire to to let this in because he's
saying that he loves me and I had never
heard that before so it just starts to
feel very good and I
decided to be with him
um physically and so
I lost my virginity to him and
a month later I found out that I was
pregnant
and um
and I knew sorry you're okay take a take
a breath it's hard this probably is not
a story you just openly share all the
time right no it's
no thank you for all thank you for
honoring me with your trust
take your time thank you
um
anyway
I knew
before I even told him that I was
pregnant I I knew that he was going to
want me to have an abortion which was
difficult for me
but I started to feel very guilty
um
for you know if I keep it and what that
would do to him and his family
and um because I was very good about
just kind of keeping this bubble that we
were in
um and you know I told him look I know
like I don't expect you to ever leave
her for me I know you made a commitment
like I'm fine with just keeping this
just the way it is with us we'll just
keep it in this little box
um and then when I got pregnant you know
everything changed and you know he
wants so many words but I could tell he
was very much wanting me to get an
abortion and so
I decided to just gut it up and do it
and uh the aftermath of that was very
painful
um
and so I can tell by by the by just how
you're talking about it is it still
painful
yeah
um
and shame
um and so he gave that to me and then
you know several months go by and
I feel very lonely and very confused and
so
um I let him back in and
so we
resumed the affair and his wife his wife
has no ideas has been going on
and he said
yes I think she knows that I'm having an
affair but she won't ask about it
and that took me by surprise and I said
why and he was like
because then we would have to deal with
it
um you know just
like keep that wall up kind of thing so
let me just let me hop in here so
why now why end this
why have you reached the end here
because you've been through a lot of
what I would consider like roadblocks
and you've chosen to go around them and
go around them and go around them and go
around them why now
because I'm getting older and I see
everyone around me all my friends you
know settling down in life you know
getting married and having babies and
I'm you know
letting myself be in this situation
where it's a dead end and
um and I know it is and I know that it
it needs to end permanently because I've
I've ended it
like I said it's been on and off over
the over a few years and
I have moments where I'm very strong and
I'm like I can handle this I can you
know we can move on from each other and
it's fine but then I hit these very low
low moments and
surely surely those moments include
losing that dream of being a mom even
though that wasn't a dream you thought
you had surely those moments
are you know deep down this whole thing
ends in Ash and you've known from day
one yeah there is there there cannot be
a happy ending here
yeah
like do you have any sort of remorse or
guilt for the like imagine being on the
other side of this
and if you don't if you don't say yeah I
know not really yeah you mean like being
being like in his wife's shoes you mean
yeah yeah
oh yeah
justifying in my head
um
you know I would never I don't have
anything against her I don't want to
ruin her life you have
that's that's that's a foregone
conclusion
you and him together have
well he's had
so more context he's had
for me and um whether you're one or many
or one of it doesn't matter
like I mean you can do what you can to
do some mental gymnastics to distance
yourself from it but her life is ruined
the problem is right now it's being
ruined like Sands of an hourglass she's
slowly suffocating in her own home
um
because she's married to somebody with
so little Integrity it's just staggering
to me he doesn't even have integrity
about his lack of Integrity right he
doesn't even say like I'm leaving you
because I no longer want to
be with you I want to be with somebody
else or I no longer want to be tied down
he doesn't even have integrity about
what a scumbag he is
but
I here's the only way through this is
right through it
and I think what you're trying to do is
trying to figure out a path out of this
Mass
that doesn't involve pain and that path
does not exist
and so
um
you have to
choose
I'm gonna I've I have violated my own
core sense of humanity and I did it in
the name of
love and I did it in the name of I just
put my guard down
and that's not the person I want to be
anymore that's not who I am and I know
this ends awfully and so you walk right
through that and you get a couple of
your friends and you enter into a season
of grief man because you lose somebody
that you actually do care about and you
lose somebody who yet you got pregnant
with and you lose somebody that you fell
in love with that you know deep down is
a terrible person that you could never
be with even if he left his wife and
said I'm with you forever you know you
couldn't be with him because he'd turn
around and have somebody else within the
next year
and so
the only way through it is to go through
the grief of that and I think your grief
is going to be multi-layered you're
going to have the loneliness but behind
or underneath that loneliness of missing
a guy who's probably a great lover and
he's probably funny and he knows you and
he has the Work Connection and the
intimate connection all that beneath
that
is this
like you walled yourself off from the
world to avoid this exact moment I'm
gonna stay away from men because men are
bad news and they are going to make me
violate my own core values and I'm going
to end up in places I don't want to be
and here you are
and to me that is going to be the
hardest thing you have to grieve
because everything you spent all of your
life trying to avoid has has come to
your front door and you open the door
and let it in
does that make sense
yeah I know 100 it does
so if I'm you I'm just gonna be I would
quit my job
I'd quit my job I would get so far away
because I don't want to work at a place
where that guy is either
well we don't work together anymore
um so there is
even more space
um
but yeah in a way it intensified the the
longing
between us I think
you just got to know Katie it's not real
yeah it's not real your hurt is
but this affair is not real
um
have you told any of your friends
I opened up to
one of my best friends right after I
found out I was pregnant that's when I
told her everything
um
and but she doesn't know that I went
back to him and that's another thing is
I've been utterly terrified
telling her that
it's been
years
um
of keeping it from her
because she was really there for me when
I you know had the abortion and um you
know gave me a lot of support
um but I've been afraid to let her down
you have
she just doesn't know it yet
and so the only way back through that is
to sit down with your friend that you
love and trust and say
I'm gonna break your heart because I've
broken my own
and I need some help
the definition of addiction is a
compulsive behavior that you continue to
do even after your body has identified
it's bad for you
so this isn't technically an addiction
if you will like in the classic
chemically sense substance abuse kind of
way
um
but Pia Melody one of the great authors
talks about something called love
addiction this idea that I cannot I
can't walk away from something that I
know is going to kill me it's it's it's
actively killing me the secrets the
disgust I feel when I look in the mirror
the disgust when I'm driving home and
he's going home to his wife and his kids
this other imaginary life he has and I'm
going home alone
and then you keep going back even even
though you know and you know and you
know so I tell you that to tell you you
can't do this by yourself
you can't do this by yourself
you're gonna have to reach out to a
friend that you care and risk that
friend saying I don't want to be friends
with somebody who would do that
or maybe she opens her arms up really
big and says this ends today but I'll
walk with you
and my guess is untangling all these
emotions and all these years and all of
the secrecy and all the times you've had
to not be honest with your other
co-workers and your friends and your
family
going through an abortion alone
all of it
that panic when those times over the
last few years when you think his wife
is calling you or emailing you or
figured something all of that you're
gonna have to get somebody to untangle
that with you
and then ultimately you have to get to a
place where you forgive Katie and then
you make a covenant with yourself that
that never happens again that you honor
Katie enough
to never
get involved this way systematically
again
and I hope you hear my voice I'm with
you
I'm sad for you
I am
but I'm with you
and I'm not gonna sit here and beat you
up
and everybody listening
from your little keyboards throwing
grenades on this situation is not going
to help it is what it is it's already
burned to the ground
there's just a couple of survivors
staggering around
I think this ends today
I think you commit to yourself and to
him and to everybody around you it's the
last time we speak this last time I
talked to you I block you on everything
I drop everything you are out of my life
and for good you might have to move
Apartments you might have to do all quit
your job I don't care what you have to
do
you're gonna drown in this
this is the moment when the alcoholic
takes all the bottles and pours them
down the sink you gotta walk away
and then you gotta look around at the
burn down landscape of your life and say
I
people help me rebuild this thing can be
rebuilt 100
[Music]
but the lying and the deception and the
secrets and the
utter violation over years
of your own Integrity of your this
person's poor wife and kids all of it
stops today
and I'll be with you every step of the
way Katie call anytime
I'm not going to hate on you your life's
hard hard enough already I'll sit with
you figure out what to do next
please call your friend today
we'll be right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
ah there's a lot going on especially in
the economy you're hearing words like
recession continued inflation thrown
around and it's making your stress
levels Spike I don't care who you are
but remember we've been through Seasons
like this before and the best thing you
can do is focus on controlling what you
can control you can control your
spending and saving you can you can
control your daily habits you can
and you can control making time for
sleep and this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I found
that the key to good sleep starts with
an incredible mattress and that's why I
love dream Cloud mattresses they're
incredibly comfortable and right now
dream cloud is making it easy to invest
in good sleep with their biggest offer
yet 40 off all mattresses plus an
additional fifty dollars in savings
exclusively for my listeners go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
and start sleeping today
all right let's roll up to Oklahoma in
Tulsa and talk to good man Kyle what's
up Kyle
oh my gosh I am on the phone with Dr
John deloney actually I'm just AI I'm
just a computer version of myself what's
up I hope you can be just as helpful
yeah wait dude way more helpful with a
computer what's up
um
oh my gosh
um so I
have my wife and I real quick if you
don't mind go for it man uh so I've I've
been drinking an ocean of baloney
Kool-Aid uh over the last month like 60
episodes something like that and uh
yesterday I told my wife uh I cut I took
out the bananas from the freezer cut off
the tips because that's what she asked
me to do and I didn't do it because I
thought she was being silly and I told
her that it was wrong of me to do that
and invalidate her feelings just because
and
exercise my control over it and say nope
I'm not cutting off the tips and she
goes you've been listening to your
podcast again haven't you
see for all the fruit lovers out there I
got your back guys I got your back well
done Kyle I'm glad you making those big
changes
I'm still cheating on her and I still
drink too much but I'm cutting the tips
off the bananas we're starting we have
baby steps Kyle way to go yo way to go
um so my question
um my uh my oldest son is 20 years old
um he's been estranged for we've been
estranged for quite some time
um and he recently uh in the last couple
weeks uh started calling and wants to
start to
rebuild the relationship why are you
estranged
um uh
yeah
I gave him a really rough childhood
um and then when he was about 12 his mom
and I got divorced and I moved away
when you say you gave him a rough
childhood what does that mean oh shoot
um
for a long time I refuse to admit
um that I was being abusive
um nevertheless like bruises or anything
like that but just constant yelling
screaming couldn't he couldn't do
anything right
um escalating consequences
um
it was just
I can't imagine how miserable he was
growing up
what flip a switch for you man
hold on let me just say this
um I've got a little boy myself
and so I'm gonna be a super candid with
you is that cool
yeah yep I got a little boy myself and
so part of me
has an insta I can't describe it other
than it's like a thermometer like an
insta rage inside of me when I when I
hear this and
I also have like an instant sense of
compassion
because what you just said out loud is
really hard to do
there's not and there's not a lot of
Oklahoma dads
who are willing to look back and go what
have I done
right and so I'm proud of you what flip
that switch for you man
[Music]
unto you really
um
um but starting to listen to your show
and how you talk about
trauma and how it affects little kids
and how they hold on to that forever and
well then hold on to it it just becomes
their nervous system it just becomes
wired into their bodies right it's not
like they're like just let it go like no
that's just how their bodies have chosen
to just keep them safe so he moved away
with your ex-wife and then you get
remarried have a new family I did okay
how's that going
uh it's going awesome have you learned
from your your past mistakes oh
immensely okay for you man good for you
so then so this so he's he's almost a
grown man now and he reaches out why do
you reach out
um
so he he did come down here and he moved
in with me when he was 17
um with the agreement to finish his
final year of school
um and then covid hit and he lost all of
his new friends that he had made
um down here and so he moved back to
Wisconsin with his mom
um
and
things just got worse and worse
um there's a long long history of
lying and manipulation and just
not taking responsibility for anything
um do you know that you know how that
develops right
just just people listening if you are a
young kid
and you can't do anything right
and everything is met with screaming and
spanking times too hard and you know the
difference and
a moving Target on how do I keep dad
from getting so mad
a kid peels off and learns how to be
very deceptive and never tell the truth
because he doesn't you don't you don't
say it's a very adaptive strategy
yeah that makes perfect sense it keeps a
young kid alive
and also destroys his adulthood
because then he gets fired from jobs as
he should and he gets his his romantic
Partners leave him as they should
because he can't tell the truth he's
just become deceptive so and also this
often comes with substance abuse issues
is he struggling with that too
um no okay
good for him nope
so um what's your what's your hesitancy
there's just there's been so many
bridges burned and the original divorce
was just so extremely toxic
um the marriage was extremely toxic and
I took out a lot of my frustrations
um with my marriage on him
um because nothing was changing in the
marriage so hold on it sounds like you
burned the bridges
and anytime somebody has a relationship
dysfunction with a child I'm always
going to look at the adult in the room
and say you got to go first
so if there's ever going to be a bridge
built you've got to build it you can't
expect a kid to build that bridge back
it's not their job
yep
um and we tried
um and when when he came down here when
he was 17 to live with us
um we tried yeah but I mean you you went
from one teeter-totter to the other
like that like that's that's a lot
because even if he wants to if he moves
back in with you
as a 20 year old as a 17 year old
he may want to with all of his heart to
refine his dad and who am I and I've
I've grown up and all those things dad
used to get so mad at me about I'm good
it's different now
but that 17 year old's body is every
time you walk in the room is like run
every time you give him something to
like a a chore or say hey I told you to
pick up that that whatever and you were
right to tell him his body goes to
Defcon one
and so I I think you over hit it right
you over corrected from abusive to
completely out of my life to move back
in that's a lot versus
let's be I mean you can't just drop a
newly fully formed Bridge across a a big
river right you got to build it slat by
slat and I think that's what y'all have
to do here
yep
um there is a lot of history
um and stuff that he doesn't know about
because about what the divorce and he
doesn't matter does he need to who cares
you were a grown ass man and you treat
took it out on a kid I don't care what
was happening in your marriage I know
that sounds callous but he doesn't need
to know what happened in your marriage
and how awful his mom was he doesn't
need to know any of that
he needs his dad to sit down at a
restaurant somewhere between here and
Wisconsin and say I wrote a letter that
I'm going to read to you
and it starts with dear son I'm so sorry
I let you down
I didn't know what I was doing I was
over my head my marriage was a wreck I
had no Tools in my tool kit and I loved
you and I showed you in the worst
possible way
and I've sent you on a path to learning
to be dishonest to get what you need
because I couldn't give it to you and I
didn't give it to you and fill in the
blank the only way this works Kyle is
you take a knee in front of that
one-year-old and say I've failed you and
that ends today
and I did okay how'd that go
um I'm proud of you for doing that by
the way that takes a lot of Courage I
make it sound all easy on the radio
that's hard to do how'd that go it's
probably the it was probably the hardest
thing I'd ever said to anybody in my
life did you feel 50 pounds lighter when
you after you're saying that stuff
oh yeah I bet so so so yes so tell me uh
how to go
um went good
um he thanked me for being honest about
it because it's what he had accused me
of for years and I denied it yeah
um and I think because when he first
called me I was like man I don't know if
I can do this with him right now
um
it doesn't count over the phone by the
way yeah over the phone to Step One it
has to happen in person so if you all
talked on the phone and you said a bunch
of stuff that's cool that's a cool like
partial First Step but that's not it
yep
um so yeah we're trying to set up a time
to meet he was in Iowa now
um so we're trying to set up a time that
we can meet and get together Kyle
don't set up a time get in your car and
go see your son
this isn't something you arrange this
isn't something that you walk out of
your job and say I'll be back I'm going
to get my son
like the the
even if you drive all the way from Tulsa
to Iowa for a two and a half or three
hour meal together and then you drive
home
but he has to know dad's coming to get
me
there's no more tiptoeing and this like
what happened has happened the only
thing you can change is what happens
next
Fair
absolutely Fair
and here's how I think you
here's how I think you guys start
building those slots back I think you
make a commitment to yourself and to him
I'm going to write him a letter every
week and mail it to him
just thinking about you wouldn't you
know I'm so proud of you I want you and
I love you
one time you're not probably gonna
remember this but one time when you're a
little kid fill in the blank that's it
and what's gonna happen in real short
order by the end of this time next year
he's gonna have 52 letters from his old
man he's even gonna get annoyed that you
keep sending them
and after letter 36 he's like Dad I'm
we're good you don't keep sending these
you're like I know
but you will never go another week of
your life not knowing that your dad
loves you and is committed all in on you
now that does not mean he gets access to
your checking account that doesn't mean
that you become an ATM for him or
whatever
that means I'm gonna love you so why did
he Reach Out
no I'm going to
no no why did he reach out oh why did he
reach out
um
so a lot of the patterns that I put on
him when he was a kid he's exhibiting
now as a young adult yeah and he got
as far as I know got kicked out of his
mom's house
and just say not being kind to his
younger sister okay
there is a moment when you confront your
son on that
and you say I I let you down you cannot
let the cycle continue it has to stop
with you
what's up with me and SW
yep is he calling he's kind of where I'm
struggling yeah go ahead because
but I know all these things about
that he's kept secret from me as far as
his home life and
fighting with his sister and his mom and
I I feel responsible for that and at the
same time I also feel like
he needs to be held accountable for that
because some of it's his own decisions
um he's a 20 year old man now he's a 20
year old man that's exactly right
and
sometimes accountability looks like hey
I can't get you out of jail I'll hold
your hand I'll sit with you
you're not gonna do this alone
his experiences now are a context not an
excuse he does not have free reign
because you didn't show up for him as a
kid he does not have free reign to burn
other people to the ground
he's got to be held accountable good for
his mom for kicking him out of his house
if he's making it unsafe for his little
sister good for her for holding
upholding boundaries and if he's
reaching out he didn't see that coming
well if he's reaching out to you just
because he's looking for a crash pad you
only need to have that conversation
because he has no interest in in
rebooting your relationship he has ever
interest in just getting free rent and
that's two different things that's kind
of what I'm worried about is that the
reach out was for ulterior motives
probably probably
but tell him
I love you too much we are combustible
we're gonna have to build this thing
back slowly
and I will contribute a couple hundred
bucks a month to an apartment out here
if you want to move out here but you're
gonna have to work too
oh my gosh after all this you're just
gonna no no I love you so much you gotta
learn some lessons that I should have
taught you when you were little and
I can't sleep at night if I let the
scene continue
yeah so I think I think the re-entry
here has to be you and your new wife
setting the boundaries right like
yeah son I don't engage with folks that
lie that's a that's a choice as a grown
man that I've made
I also don't walk away from people that
I love
so I'm asking you don't choose to walk
away from me by being dishonest
number two
when you move back in here that was not
we have to learn we have to teach our
bodies at each other is safe
it's not going to work for you just to
move back in here apartments in this
area are this much I'll contribute this
much
I'll call my buddy at the shop to help
you get a job or whatever he's doing
help him get to college or whatever
but and there's going to be some stars
to stop some ups and downs he's going to
get mad you can invite him to counseling
with you if you'd like to
But ultimately you can't be responsible
for his healing as much as you want to
try to get a redo on that what happens
what you can do is love him right now
but he's a grown man now he's got to
make his own choices which is hard
yep I'm trying to support him
anyway but financially I did send him
your show he started listening he went
all the way back to the first episode
he's listening from the back forward
um
I I think you let him know hey I'm
coming on Saturday
I'm coming next Friday
I'm taking you to dinner
and I think you and your wife figure out
how to make that happen financially
and time wise
and you know talked on in person but you
got to look him in the eye and I'd write
it down man because it can get real
heavy and it can get real blubbery and
be very hard I would look him in the eye
and read that letter to him
and then from there say what do you need
how can I love you right now
and then align what he's asked for with
those new boundaries
but yeah you may have taught him some
things as a young kid that doesn't give
him license to run over his little
sister or his mom or anybody like that
and here's the thing
did you play that right when he was
young no you did you let him down
and have you made it a mission in your
life to
not only
create new paths for your family that
you have now your new family but also
provide opportunities for him
to be a the dad that he didn't have
growing up absolutely and I commend you
for that it's hard
it's day by day there's a lot of guilt
and there's gonna be moments that come
up things probably you forgot that he
remembers you're going to feel guilty
about the challenge for you is going to
be to not go to shame
you did some stupid stuff when you were
young and in a toxic marriage but you're
not stupid stuff
that's the difference between guilt and
shame something you did versus something
you are
because now you're not that guy anymore
you're the dad that's going to run out
after his prodigal son and say please
come home I'm sorry
please come home
and by the way you can't stay in the
house you can stand apartment down the
street
and you got to get a job you gotta go to
college
and I'll meet with you once a week
that's what you want to do
I'm gonna build a relationship back
Brick by Brick by Brick
We're Not Gonna hand him the keys to a
new car we're not going to hand him the
keys to a new highway together you're
all going to rebuild this brick that for
all the parents listening
that rebuilding relationship with your
kids starts with you
starts with you what if my
Mac starts with you
you're the mom you're the dad make the
call
we'll be right back
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallo
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloney today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hollow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right we're back let's go to
Harrisburg Pennsylvania and talk to the
Great and Powerful Renee what's up Renee
Hi how are you partying how are you
I'm great that's so good what's up
um I'm currently in a relationship and
we have a daughter and
there are some things that are said in
front of her that I'm not like a fan of
during like arguments
so I'm not sure if it's like better for
her for us to be together or not
I don't even know what's being said but
I want to challenge the whole premise
okay
okay she cannot be the reason you leave
your husband or don't leave your husband
she can't carry that kind of weight
right you have to choose am I with a man
who is abusive and childish and let's
take her out of the equation
almost zero percent chance that he's
perfect in every other way and your
relationship is humming along except for
he says appropriate things in front of
your daughter Fair
great so back out and like be honest are
you out of this relationship are you
done
uh sometimes I feel that way
tell me about that
um
it seems like things will go really well
for a while and we communicate really
well and then like all of a sudden like
something happens and it's um like a big
argument that kind of lasts for days and
at that point I'm kind of like
it's hard for me to like trust again
that that's not going to continue to
happen of course because it keeps it
keeps continuing right yeah that keeps
happening who who is the adult who has
the adult body but acts like a child and
keeps an argument going on for days
because that's that's a power move
that's not let's solve this problem or
you really hurt my feelings that's a
power move that's a way to run a
household by keeping a fight going on
and on and on is that you that does that
or is that him
um I feel like it's him would he tell me
on the phone that it's you
yes
so what is it that he's doing
um there's a lot of like kind of insults
and really like harsh like words that
are kind of coming to me and at that
point I kind of like everything is all
kind of let's just get right to the the
reality like it kind of is mean and kind
of is the greatest ever what does he say
um he'll say that I'm stupid and that
there's other there's other like curse
words that are being used
and things in reference to me so as an
adult
I choose to not be in a conversation or
relationship with people that angrily
swear at me on a regular basis
right I choose that
why do you think so little of yourself
that you haven't made that choice
um because that's a child
like that's a that's a very childish
thing to do
yeah
just swear and curse at your wife when
you're mad that's just that's what kids
do man
yeah
do you do it back
no I usually like I kind of shut down
and I'll try to walk away from the
situation if that's happening because I
mean I don't really want to deal with
that and I don't feel like that's gonna
produce a positive conversation good for
you
and then when you re-establish control
in your relationship by walking away and
choosing dignity over just getting
berated
he chooses to sulk and hmm and just
carry it on for days and weeks on end
yeah he does not like the walking away
have you ever told him with a smile on
your face if you would stop
swearing at me and cussing at me and
telling me that was stupid I wouldn't
walk away
actually you know what that gives him
back I want to flip that around I said
that wrong
I think the best way to say it is no I'm
always I always have autonomy
and so I choose to not be around people
who swear and curse at me so if you
swear and curse at me and throw a temper
tantrum like a child
you are choosing for me to go away and I
get the message loud and clear
yeah and I I mean this past week I kind
of because we had like a big fight last
week like that and I kind of
set that boundary where I was like if
that's happening like I'm not going to
be a part of it it's not like acceptable
I can't really continue in a
relationship where that's going to
happen all right so you practice you you
to use your words you kind of put down a
boundary and then what happened did he
say oh no no no no I didn't want that or
he'd say yeah that's right
um like why are you calling do you think
this thing's over
yeah it's hard for me to like kind of
let them go so I feel like I hold on to
some like anger and hurt from those
types of situations you should hold on
to anger and hurt it's ugly it's hard
a guy stood before you and God and your
friends and said I'm all in on you and I
will I will commit to service to you for
the rest of our marriage and you said
the same to him
you know follow that up with you stupid
fill in the blank
yeah
even when you're mad even when you're
just incredibly angry
you don't talk like that
right to me like I know if I'm kind of
getting to a point where I'm angry and I
can kind of pause on that and like come
back to it later and he tends to be very
like explosive yeah
are you safe otherwise does he punch the
wall or throw things at you
no
do you push him so far and poke and prod
and prod and poke and do things you know
you're gonna set him off
I don't think so
what would he say
um he says that sometimes that I like
uh Panic or
um
get emotional too easily and that's so
stupid he doesn't get to say that that's
dumb
laughs
it's just that's gaslighting 101.
yeah and I scream and yell and call
somebody stupid you stupid blankety
blank blank blank blanker and then you
start crying and it's like oh my gosh
you're so emotional
it's hard to do that after everything
that was just said yeah
I can't be the person that says you're
good you're free to go
and your daughter can't be either
right and I know that
leaving somebody with a young child
creates a Cascade of challenging
situations
yeah but that little girl as you
probably rightfully know is getting a
ringside seat she is downloading into
her nervous system this is what Love and
Marriage looks like and this is how a
woman is to be treated by a man
right and that's like the part that
makes me feel like guilty the part that
should make you feel guilty is the part
that loves and cares for Renee
deserves more
because there's a little girl inside of
you going is this what we're worth
and so it like all that like Kumbaya
stuff here's the deal if I'm you I would
let my husband know not in kinda terms
I've made a an appointment next whatever
for us to go see a marriage counselor or
one of those two-day we're gonna figure
out at the end of this two-day Retreat
Terry reel does these across the
countries many many therapists in many
countries I mean in many cities do this
we're coming in for 48 hours for a
Friday night and all day Saturday and we
all agree at the end of that Saturday
whether we're staying together or not
we're calling it
like do we have what it takes or do we
have the investment to work on this
thing and if we do here's the behaviors
they're going to change immediately and
here's what we're going to work for
together or I'm not into that
I don't want to work on that
and then cool we make an agreement at
five o'clock on Saturday or noon on
Sunday we shake hands and then we go to
mediation we call it there's a lot of
therapists that do that kind of program
I think you that's where y'all are at
I'd agree
so I'd make the call and remember this
behavior is a language if he doesn't
show up he has told you everything you
need to know
yeah
if he says I'm not going to some stupid
marriage counselor to listen I don't
hear none of that you're not going
nowhere quit whining it he's told you
everything you need to know he's not
invested in the future of this
relationship
he is leaving by absence
yeah
is that fair
guy just threw a lot at you what are you
feeling
um it makes me nervous to like kind of
bring the idea up but I like the idea
let me say this Renee the idea is out
I promise he's not sitting with his
buddies right now being like man my wife
is the best my marriage is amazing
yeah he knows it's falling apart too
or it's gone
yeah and
sometimes it just takes somebody to say
I'm willing to rebuild if you are
and that that doesn't mean great there's
still a lot of construction that has to
be done and a lot of remodeling and a
lot of excavation has to be done but
if you both say you're in you're in just
take somebody to say it out loud
if he came back if y'all went to a
counseling session he said oh my gosh
I'm I'm sorry I've done this all
sideways I'm willing to do it to be
different would you would that give you
peace would you be like awesome my man
or are you done with him
has he said things he says he said
things that you can't come back from I'm
not judging either way I just want to
know
like I I think I could be to
time to kind of trust that that's
not gonna just
be the same thing that's fair very good
very cool and if he wants to call in
have him call in I'd love to hear his
side of the uh of this story or if you
want to call in together I'd love to
hear that that side too
yeah this is you've heard me say this a
million times and I'll probably say a
million more before the show's over
um this is a moment when you gotta turn
the lights on turn the music off and say
okay this is this is the state of our
marriage you talk to me this way and I
will not have that anymore you think I'm
the most annoying this and that and this
and that from these behaviors I we gotta
solve this thing
you don't like being the dad of a young
daughter I I don't like being in a house
where people are screaming we're
teaching our daughters what love looks
like all those things have to be said
and you'll also have to recognize we us
too we don't have the tools in our tool
kits to solve this moving forward
because we would have done that by now
we got to go sit with a professional
I've made an appointment
if you're in it's on Friday
will you join me I hope you will
and that's how this goes man
and he can say no I'm out
oh
and you probably need to see that
counselor anyway because there's going
to be somebody that walks alongside you
through whatever comes next
but all said and done you're not crazy
for not wanting to be around somebody
that swears and curses at you and calls
you stupid
and he's probably not crazy for getting
frustrated at whatever
question is
not can we go back to the way things
were the way things were over
are we both in to building something
completely new
My Hope Is y'all choose yes
but if it's too far gone it's too far
gone be honest be bold be a person of
integrity
you make your next steps we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings in
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're wrapping up today's show
I have a follow-up uh email to read to
you check this out previous call was on
June 29th 2021 which seems like a
thousand years ago it's from Susie in
Lubbock Texas Susie writes I was just
listening to the show and felt compelled
to reach out to you it was two years ago
that I emailed Dr John for advice on my
son getting divorced his family his
wife's family spurted on and what my
part in that situation should be his
advice really helped me but not
immediately
Susie she writes LOL LOL lots of love or
laugh out loud
um
I didn't want to do what he said I
should I wanted to jump in and fix
everything and I wanted him to tell me
how to fix it but that's not at all what
he told me he basically told me I needed
to be the best and most loving person I
could be encourage my son to do the same
and let go of trying to control the
outcome I mean what not an easy thing
for me to do I might be a control freak
but I really tried to apply his advice
as best I could and as time went on it
got easier now two years later my son is
in a better place mentally than he was
then for sure he's thriving and he's
such a good dad I'm super proud they are
co-parenting my precious three-year-old
grandson well I continue to listen to
the show because it helps me in so many
ways and also I say lots of prayers for
you the callers I guess I just really
wanted to say thank you for all you'll
do it matters thank you for your hearts
to love on others Susie
just transitioning from being a control
freak to someone who loves and can sit
lovingly in that awful discomfort
is really hard real hard and I'm super
proud of you it's incredible work good
for you good for you anyway let's be
honest this didn't have the happy ending
you were hoping for
hit her parents didn't back out and the
marriage was saved and everybody lived
happily ever after
but it sounds like they're being adults
and they have built something else
that might be arguably not as good but
they're co-parenting well and I happen
to believe that part of what's making
that go well is your son knows I'm
anchored into my mom who loves me and
will be there even when she disagrees
with me she still loves me good for you
Susie good for you and thank you for
continuing continuing to listen to the
show if anybody is listening it has
follow-ups or where are they now please
send them in John deloney.com ask
and for everybody else stay in school be
nice to each other be kind
don't do drugs all this all the
electrical school special stuff call
Zach Morris on your big phone
and the great Kelly kaplowski kapolski
what was her name Kapowski Kapowski
koplowski Kapowski Kelly Capouse get it
right
I love you guys bye
[Music]